from those who took a stand then so we
could walk now
to today's stars who are passionately
taken to the streets
calling for racial equality the future
of black entertainment
sure does look
[Music]
he right love me late stars like billy
holliday and muhammad ali
stuck to their convictions drawing
national attention to causes like racial
oppression
and the vietnam war billy holliday died
in 1959
at just 44 years old but among her
achievements
she's remembered for her contribution to
the civil rights movement
[Music]
her rendition of the song strange fruit
a song based on a poem about
lynching drew public attention to racial
injustice
i think we should use our platform in
which to help to influence people
and enlighten people harry belafonte
musician and recipient of a grammy
lifetime achievement award
has been an advocate for political and
humanitarian causes
throughout his life i don't see what i
do as courageous
i see martin luther king as courageous
harry provided for king's family
bailed him out of birmingham city jail
during the 1963 birmingham campaign
financed the 1961 freedom rights and
helped organize the 1963 march on
washington
fast forward to current day and beyonce
is one of the stars carrying the torch
the 79-time grammy-nominated singer is
taking an
impactful stance against police
brutality and injustice
through her music in her visual album
for lemonade she included the mothers of
trayvon martin
michael brown and eric garner
fans of insecure actor kendrick sampson
have seen him elevate
mental health issues in the black
community on and off the screen for
years but
last summer his non-profit organization
build power
collaborated with black lives matter la
on many demonstrations
and i want to go home i wonder if i go
home will people see that the 32 year
old continued to show up
after being hit by rubber bullets and a
police baton
at a peaceful protest you you get your
people y'all walked beside us
what a powerful exchange happened
between kiki palmer and the national
guard
soldiers at a black lives matter protest
in los angeles
last june and it left fans inspired
march beside us
and show us that you're here for us
there's a young generation that's you
know becoming the new voters and the new
people of the world
we got to understand that we got to make
make do what we have and really figure
out how to make a way out of nowhere